the Social Democrats haven't forgotten
how to party just three weeks after
their worst election results in modern
German history the SPD is back coming
out as the strongest party in Lower
Saxony for the first time in nearly 20
years this is a great evening for the
SPD and Lower Saxony and for me many
thanks to the voters but also to my
party members who fought passionately
it's a remarkable turnaround in the
summer the SPD was far behind in polling
the victory in Lower Saxony was badly
needed after party leader Martin Schultz
as historic defeat in the Bundestag
elections I think what the Social
Democrats achieved in Lower Saxony is
unique in the history of election
campaigns in Germany and we're not only
thankful but we're also very proud and
very happy about this great success SPD
lead candidate band Altos man and his
conservative CDU party lost 2% scoring
their lowest results in almost twenty
years personally I would have wished for
a better result for the CDU party and
Lower Saxony but let me be absolutely
clear about this we do not have to be
ashamed about the nice results the
result weakens Chancellor Merkel who is
facing a difficult time at the
negotiating table another party got a
big bump out of the results the
far-right alternative for Germany won
seats in the regional Parliament for the
first time that means it's now
represented in 14 federal states of
Germany